attirer de nouveaux publics à Versailles
c'est tout l'enjeu du partenariat établi
entre le château et les éditions Glénat
le 26 septembre sortait le premier album
de bande dessinée le crépuscule du roi
nous allons faire trois albums sur le
sujet trois albums qui seront
indépendants le fil rouge sera le
château ce sera la seule le seul lien
entre les trois albums qui pourront se
lire tout à fait indépendamment pourquoi
ce choix comment vous est venu cette
idée c'est une collection que développe
les éditions Glénat qui est une
collection sur les grands lieux du
patrimoine il y a eu un album sur le
Mont-Saint-Michel sur Carnac en Bretagne
un autre sur le Panthéon sur le pendule
de Foucault et là donc il va y avoir ces
trois albums sur le château de
Versailles et donc il y a des lecteurs
de BD qui vont découvrir Versailles à
travers leurs livres favoris leur
manière de découvrir les choses
favorites on peut découvrir Versailles à
travers la musique les romans la
peinture la visite de Versailles
évidemment et bien là on va la découvrir
grâce à la bande dessinée qui nous fait
remonter dans le temps puisque cette
trilogie nous emmène dans le futur et
puis après va nous ramener dans le
présent pour nous transporter ensuite
dans le passé
je dirais que bon il est toujours une
certaine exactitude historique à
apporter mais on a aussi la possibilité
de parler les cadrages les points de vue
qu'on choisit d'apporter aussi notre
univers donc sans justement repasser par
le côté carte postale ou film de déjà vu
donc c'est moi qui m'a vraiment
intéressé c'est ça c'est d'essayer
d'injecter d'enversize
un peu de mes visions à moi on commence
sans une histoire
classique traditionnelle il y a un roi
on connaît pas trop son numéro mais on
va tout se passe bien les nobles font
des histoires de nobles les chambrières
font des histoires de chambrière et puis
il y a quelque chose qui se passe d'un
seul coup on ressent des petits
anachronismes et des petites choses
anormales dans le dans l'histoire ça ne
devrait pas se passer comme ça surtout
que après tout les serveurs s'appellent
tous
Roberts qui servent les roberts partout
et ce Robert de temps en temps ils ont
plutôt une allure de robot et ce château
on ne peut pas en sortir si on passe les
grilles de ce château on rentre dans un
univers extrêmement angoissant
extrêmement anxiogène
l'album de science-fiction le crépuscule
du roi sera suivi d'un deuxième tome
intitulé l'ombre de la reine le nom du
dernier album est déjà connu il s'agira
du sacrifice du Fou